the funniest thing is like since it's
Zoom therapy one time I had like 10
minutes to kill before therapy you know
men rub the one out you hate that saying
JK up I don't know what the no my I was
listened to your podcast last night my
new thing I hate the most is bricked up
bricked up is great I ha brick up is
great that's how you got the baby with
me I hate it but red up but if you ever
jerk off before therapy or MK before
therapy it is hilarious you click enter
and he's like how are you I'm like I'm
lighting a cigarette I'm like I don't
even smoke but I'm good man how are the
kids he's like I don't have kids I'm
like up I'll see you next week I heard
on your podcast that you sometimes jerk
off on all
fours uh I guess that would be threes
wait threes three point St or that what
that or in doggy style like doggy Stu do
you put a hand on the wall I've done
that how does that I always thought that
guys jerked off by like the way that you
like stand at a urinal like with your
hand up like maybe if you're like 57